ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen
international wächst die militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine nur so ist
zumindest die internationale Wahrnehmung
Deutschland steht auf der Bremse und das
damit isoliert sich die Bundesregierung
außenpolitisch das ist zumindest die
Sorge und die Wahrnehmung vieler darüber
sprechen wir heute in der Sendung wie
immer auch gerne mit Ihnen und Euch
fragen wie immer in die Kommentare oder
wenn ihr und sie die ZDF heute-app nutzt
die eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
mit dabei heute Abend ist die Chefin des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Deutschen
Bundestag Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann
von der FDP schönen guten Abend schön
dass Sie dabei sind Frau Ströck
Zimmermann und bevor wir in die
Diskussion einsteigen und damit wir alle
auf Stand sind erstmal ein kleiner
Überblick dazu was denn die Deutschen im
Moment machen und wie der aktuelle Stand
der Diskussion ist was es zum Beispiel
geben soll ist ein Ringtausch Klaus
Brodbeck berichtet
darum geht es T-72 Panzer aus Sowjet
Seiten wie diese hier sollen von
osteuropäischen Partnern etwas Slowenien
an die Ukraine geliefert und von ihr
sofort eingesetzt werden dabei
entstehende Lücken könnten dann nach und
nach mit Panzern aus Deutschland wieder
aufgefüllt werden dieser Ringtausch
würde gewährleisten dass schnell
geliefert werden kann und vor allen
Dingen ohne erforderliche
Ausbildungszeiten das ist das was die
Ukraine jetzt braucht wir stehen zur
Verfügung diese Staaten zu unterstützen
die aus ihren Beständen jetzt leisten
damit ihre
Landesverteidigung dann nicht geschwächt
wird möglicher Ersatz Marder aus
Deutschland geliefert allerdings nicht
direkt von der Bundeswehr sondern aus
Beständen der Industrie die erst noch
aufgearbeitet werden müssen die weitere
Verschärfung des Kurses gegen Russland
zeichnete sich heute auch beim Besuch
der Außenministerin in Estland ab
Werbung kündigt dort ein neues
Sanktionspaket an die Arbeiten an diesem
nächsten Paket in Brüssel die laufen
bereits wir werden den Druck auf die
russische kriegsmaschineie weiter
erhöhen und gleichzeitig alles dafür tun
um die Ukraine mit Waffen und Ausrüstung
weiter zu unterstützen auch solche
Radpanzer Fuchs könnte Deutschland aus
Industrie Beständen abgeben die Kritik
an der Bundesregierung hält dennoch an
aus meiner Sicht muss man halt mal
entscheiden was man jetzt will man
Waffen liefern ja oder nein und wenn wie
das was im Moment gemacht wird in der
lässt im gesamten internationalen
Ausland ein seltsames Gefühl der
Instabilität auch Ausbildungen
Panzerhaubitzen in Deutschland soll nun
möglich werden lange hatte die Regierung
das abgelehnt
Zimmermann ein seltsames Gefühl der
Instabilität so nennt es der bayerische
Ministerpräsident wir schauen mal gleich
ins Netz und sehen zum Beispiel einen
Tweet von Donald Turk dem ehemaligen
ehemaligen polnischen
Ministerpräsidenten der wenn man das
übersetzt sinngemäß sagt die Deutschen
müssen jetzt entschlossen die Ukraine
unterstützen um glaubhaft zu machen dass
sie die richtigen Schlüsse aus ihrer
eigenen Geschichte gezogen haben Frau
Zimmermann wie groß ist ihre Sorge um
das internationale Ansehen Deutschlands
ich habe natürlich Sorge und Deutschland
um das internationale auch der denken
manche von uns den Eindruck den manche
von uns haben könnten ich glaube wenn
die Bundesregierung anders kommuniziert
hätte und auch in Zukunft da bin ich
optimistisch anders kommuniziert wäre
dieses Missverständnis nicht entstanden
denn die Bundesrepublik hat ja eine
Menge geliefert hat er aber ein
Geheimnis drum gemacht übrigens im
Vorfeld macht habe ich da Verständnis im
Nachhinein offen zu machen was man
geliefert hat hätte wahrscheinlich
diesen Eindruck nicht hinterlassen und
insofern war auch mein Wunsch und meine
Bitte an den Bundeskanzler etwas offener
etwas klarer zu kommunizieren damit wir
nicht von aufgrund von
Missverständnissen da in ein falsches
Licht gerückt werden
wenn man sich ihre Kritik der
vergangenen Tage und Wochen auch
anschaut dann haben Sie nicht nur Kritik
an der Kommunikation sondern auch
inhaltlich an der Frage der
Waffenlieferungen und sie haben deutlich
gefordert dort mehr zu tun wie ist das
stand heute
in der Tat wir leben ja in einer kann
man sagen eine sehr dynamischen Lage und
vor sechs sieben Wochen wir sind jetzt
schon im 57 Tag dieses grausam Überfalls
war die Diskussion in Deutschland auf
eine andere auch ich auch meine
Kolleginnen Kollegen waren sehr
zurückhaltend dass das Thema Panzer vor
allen Dingen betrifft wir haben
allerdings relativ früh darauf
hingewiesen dass wir die Ukraine
unterstützen sollten mit Waffen jetzt
sind einige Wochen vergangen und die
Lager hat sich insofern verändert dass
die Grausamkeit
offenbart wird dass also nicht nur in
Anführungszeichen gegen Soldaten
gekämpft sondern auch Zivilisten
umgebracht werden sie kennen die Bilder
Kinder verschleppt Frauen vergewaltigt
also
Geburtskliniken bombardiert also alles
entmenschlichste was man nur vorstellen
kann und wie auch merken dass Wladimir
Putin ist ernst meint damit die Ukraine
von der Landkarte zu löschen und
deswegen sind wir jetzt alle
aufgefordert gemeinsam mit den Partnern
auch schweres Material zu schicken die
Sprachen gerade davon von Panzern von
panzerhof Witzen vielleicht noch ein
Wort wir hatten vor drei Wochen schon
vorgeschlagen als Freie Demokraten dass
man diesen Ringtausch angeht das macht
auch Sinn weil das eben Material das
russischen beständnis was die Ukraine
umgehend einsetzen kann und dafür
bekommt eben dann Osteuropa unsere
Partner in der NATO neueres Material das
macht sehr großen Sinn und ich bin
erleichtert dass das jetzt in die Wege
geleitet wird ich muss noch mal
nachfragen das heißt sie fordern im
Moment über das was innerhalb der
Bundesregierung diskutiert wird hinaus
nicht mehr zu tun
doch ich fordere nach wie vor und da bin
ich auch nicht alleine ich fordere neben
den der Frage des ringtauschs das ist
jetzt der richtige Ansatz es wird
bereits Geld bereitgestellt das ist auch
gut nein ich fordere dass wir mehr
machen da wo wir etwas machen können und
das sind eben zwei Ebene das eine ist
Material zu liefern aus den Beständen
der Bundeswehr da sind wir stoßen wir an
eine Grenze das ist jetzt nicht wirklich
erstaunlich deswegen sind wir ja auch so
erleichtert dass der Bundeskanzler das
100 Milliarden Euro Paket sozusagen
geschnürt hat gemeinsam mit dem
Finanzminister Christian Lindner die
Bundeswehr also entsprechend zu einer
modernen Armee voll auszustatten das
also die Bundeswehr nicht so viel hat
wie man gerne hätte das wissen wir und
deswegen muss das was geliefert wird
darf nicht dazu führen dass die
Bundeswehr nachher am Limit ist denn wir
haben innerhalb der NATO an der
Ostflanke in Litauen unserer Aufgabe bei
einem möglichen Angriffs Russland diese
schlanke zu verteidigen
was geht ist dass man mit der Industrie
zusammenarbeitet der Ehrlichkeit halber
muss man aber sagen dass auch dieses
Material zumindest hergerichtet werden
muss und ein ganz wichtiges Thema das
uns all überall Munition fehlt also der
Beispiel Leopard der Beispiel Gebhard
das sind verschiedene Panzertypen hätten
wir selbst wenn wir sie abgegeben hätten
nicht abnehmen können weil es keine
Munition mehr auf dem Markt dazu gibt
alles sehr komplex alles nicht einfach
aber immerhin
kommt jetzt Bewegung rein und das ist
wichtig losgelöst von der
internationalen Debatte die Ukraine
brauchen dringend Unterstützung weil sie
sonst diesem Feuersturm von Russland
wirklich nicht entgehen kann nun kommen
wir noch mal zurück auf den Titel
unserer Sendung mit dem Fragezeichen
Deutschland isoliert haben wir diesen
Titel gewählt und wir schauen noch mal
auf das was zum Beispiel Wolfgang
Ischinger heute getwittert hat der
ehemalige Leiter der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz und der sagt die
internationale Stimmung hat sich leider
ist gegen Deutschland gedreht wir müssen
aus dieser Falle rasch raus denn falls
der Krieg doch für Russland erfolgreich
enden sollte wird man sonst bei der
Suche nach den Schuldigen rasch auf
Deutschland zeigen die Folgen für
Deutschland und die EU wären kaum
auszumalen
teilen Sie diese Einschätzung von
Wolfgang Ischinger oder wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe denken Sie dass es noch
nicht zu spät ist und mit dem Engagement
was man jetzt zeigt auch wenn man es
vielleicht nicht gut verkauft hat ist
man international doch so dass man nicht
als Bremser wahrgenommen wird
nein das ist noch nicht zu spät man muss
natürlich immer hinzufügen und das weiß
auch Wolfgang Ischinger dass die
Bundesrepublik nach der Annexion der
krimin bis zum Ausbruch dieses
schrecklichen Krieges über zwei
Milliarden Euro in die Hand genommen hat
und zwar ganz konkret um der Ukraine zu
helfen sei es bei Ausbildung
Polizeiausbildung Zoll bei Corona sehr
sehr sehr viel gemacht hat also wir
stehen neben der und bei der Ukraine das
ist jetzt in der Tat was sie gerade
sagen ein Kommunikationsproblem jetzt
kann man sagen tue Gutes und sprecht
darüber genau das ist ja auch das wo
meine Kollegen und ich immer darauf
hingewiesen haben dass man auch darüber
sprechen muss es hat keinen Sinn Listen
geheim zu halten wenn unsere Partner in
der NATO und in Europa ganz offen
darüber sprechen was sie liefern dass
man das noch mal nicht im Vorfeld macht
um sozusagen den Weg der Waffen in die
Ukraine nicht zu gefährden das macht
Sinn im Anschluss kann man das aber
machen um klar zu machen was wir alles
tun das ist leider nicht Zunge das ist
nicht passiert und das halte ich für
einen Fehler aber Fehler sind dazu da
dass man sie ändert und dass man anders
kommuniziert und deswegen waren das auch
immer mein Wunsch und auch meine
Aufforderung an den Kanzler die
Kommunikation zu ändern ist klären den
Menschen in Deutschland also dass das
ist ja relevant sie müssen den Menschen
erst mal erklären was passiert da was
ist Deutschland bereit zu geben wo gibt
es möglicherweise Probleme das ist ja in
Deutschland bekannt die Ausstattung der
Bundeswehr und wenn das alles nicht
stattfindet wenn das alles sozusagen
sehr geheim gehalten wird dann geht es
um missinterpretation und unserer
Aufgabe ist es dass das Kanzleramt auch
im Gesprächen mit unseren Partnern
darüber spricht erklärt ich habe sehr
viel Kontakt zu internationalen
Botschaftern und da erkläre ich das und
das kommt auch an wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf dann haben wir dazu eine
eine Frage von einem User namens Ismael
04 der fragt über Youtube Frau streckt
Zimmermann die uniol will in Union will
in der kommenden Woche einen Antrag zur
Lieferung von schweren Waffen einbringen
würden Sie dem zustimmen und gerne würde
ich noch die Frage anhängen sie haben ja
auch ebenfalls heute den Kanzler
aufgefordert im Verteidigungsausschuss
über die Waffenlieferungen zu berichten
mit welchem Ziel tun sie das
also ich fange mit letzterem an ich habe
den Kanzler nicht aufgefordert sondern
als Ausschussvorsitzende habe ich den
Kanzler eingeladen ob er eine Stunde
Zeit für uns hat das ist kein
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang noch am 13 januar
2016 war Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel
auch im Ausschuss um über ihre aberheit
zu berichten bzw dass wir in die
Diskussion kommen also keine
Aufforderung keine Vorladung sondern
eine höflichen Bitte und wir würden uns
natürlich sehr freuen wenn der Kanzler
kommen könnte das zweite was Ismael was
sie gerade fragen die Union hat
angekündigt einen Antrag zu stellen es
gibt noch keinen Antrag insofern wie man
sich zu einem solchen Antrag verhält
muss man natürlich erstmal den Text
kennen tatsache ist aber dass ich auch
mit Unionsabgeordneten in Kontakt stehe
nämlich dahingehend dass wir eine breite
Zusammenarbeit brauchen zwischen
Regierung der Ampel und der
christlich-demokratischen Union weil es
geht hier um ein wirklich nationales
internationales Thema und deswegen alles
gut wir ziehen an einen Strang
parlamentarisch ist es so dass wenn ein
solcher Antrag gestellt würde dann geht
in der Regel das in die Fachausschüsse
es ist kein Gesetzesvorhaben über das
man sozusagen unmittelbar abstimmt
insofern muss ich mir erstmal den Text
angucken ich hoffe dass wir gemeinsam
und ich betone gemeinsam mit der
Opposition mit der CDU ein Weg finden
wie wir eben mehr Dynamik reinbringen in
die ganze Sache mehr liefern schneller
liefern in Absprache mit unseren
Partnern
Booster Rooster fragt über Youtube Frau
Zimmermann inwiefern verhindern
Waffenlieferungen zusätzliche Tote in
der Ukraine
ja das ist eine Diskussion oder eine
Frage mit der wir alle immer wieder
konfrontiert werden nach dem Motto
schickt keine Waffen dann hört der Krieg
auf das ist wenn ich das mir erlauben
darf zu antworten schon zynisch den
Menschen in der Ukraine gegenüber die
ein Land haben was völkerrechtswidrig
überfallen wurde die sich zur Wehr
setzen die sich nicht unter die knote
Russlands begeben wollen sehr tapfer
kämpfen und auch völkerrechtlich auf der
richtigen Seite stehen der nie un sagt
ein eindeutig dass man sich
völkerrechtlich wehren darf wenn man
überfallen wird die Lieferung von Waffen
macht sich keiner leicht aber die
Antwort wäre wenn wir es nicht tun das
Russland die Ukraine bereits besetzen
würde und das wäre das Ende der Ukraine
die Ukraine das hat Wladimir Putin immer
wieder betont soll von der Erdfläche in
den territorialen Grenzen verschwinden
und insofern unterstützen wir es dass
die Ukraine wehrhaft ist dass dabei
immer mehr Menschen sterben das ist eine
Tragödie aber ich glaube wir sollten wir
die wir im zu sitzen wenn ich das so
sagen darf im sicheren im warmen ist
letztlich der Ukraine überlassen wenn es
zu einem Frieden kommt wie diese
auszusehen hat das haben wir nicht zu
beurteilen und deswegen stehe ich dazu
und meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
die Ukraine entsprechend zu mit Waffen
zu unterstützen dass sie dieser
aggressionsstand hält nun ist die Angst
in Deutschland groß je nachdem wie man
das jetzt formuliert in diesen Krieg
aktiv mit hineingezogen zu werden es
gibt eine neue Umfrage Trendbarometer
von RTL und NTV da sind 51 Prozent für
Offensivwaffen und schweres Gerät und 37
Prozent sind dagegen das ist zwar eine
Mehrheit aber es ist keine satte
Mehrheit die Deutschen haben haben Angst
das muss man feststellen und das ist ja
auch immer wieder eine
Argumentationslinie des Bundeskanzlers
gewesen dass es keinen nato-bündnisfall
geben soll und wir sehen dass es schon
am Wochenende offenbar ein
Protestschreiben der Russen gegeben hat
an verschiedene manche Länder die
Washington Post hat darüber berichtet
und unter anderem haben die Russen
Tschechien davor gewarnt Waffen
sowjetischer Bauart an die Ukraine zu
liefern wenn sie sich diese Drohungen
und Reaktionen aus Russland angucken und
überhaupt dass das Gebaren der
russischen Politiker haben sie nicht
Sorge dass weitere Waffenlieferungen
eben doch dazu führen könnten dass man
am Ende mehr in diesen mehr in diesen
Krieg beteiligt ist als viele sich das
jetzt hier wünschen oder ausmalen
die Menschen haben Angst das weiß ich
das erreicht auch uns wir führen auch
viele Gespräche sie haben gerade die
Umfrage gesagt eine frühere Umfrage sagt
das über 70 Prozent der Deutschen gesagt
haben wir sollen an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen jetzt wo es um die
Diskussion geht über schwere Waffen
Artilleriegeschütze Panzer bekommt das
ganze ein Bild was natürlich Menschen
logischerweise beunruhigt die
Alternative wäre wir machen nichts die
Ukraine geht unter tausende von Menschen
werden ich sage das so deutlich
abgeschlachtet wir sehen tote Kinder wir
sehen ganz grauenvolle Bilder die ja
auch im Fernsehen tragischerweise aber
in dem Fall ist es gut damit man sich
diese diese grauen auch vorstellen kann
gezeigt werden wir sind nicht
Kriegspartei völkerrechtlich darf ein
Land sich verteidigen das sagte ich und
andere Länder dürfen das Land dabei
unterstützen völkerrechtlich ist das in
Ordnung was wir nicht können ist
sozusagen den Fuß auf das ukrainische
Territorium setzen also deutsche
französische tschechische Soldaten das
geht nicht dann werden wir Kriegspartei
oder sie erinnern sich noch vor paar
Wochen die Diskussion über die
Flugverbotszone das geht in der Tat
nicht weil wir dann in einen Kampf wir
die Europäer in einen Kampf mit Russland
unmittelbar eintreten würden und damit
werden wir Kriegspartei und das werden
wir alle das wollen wir nicht und das
werden wir auch nicht machen das andere
Thema was sie sagen natürlich ist
Russland nicht glücklich nicht darüber
dass der Westen der Ukraine hilft
Russland allen voran wladimir Putin hat
geglaubt dass er in fünf Tagen in Kiew
ist er hat geglaubt dass das militärisch
ein Durchmarsch ist er hat geglaubt dass
dort Menschen stehen mit Fähnchen am
Straßenrand und sich freuen wenn die
Russen kommen und er merkt dass 57 Tage
später die Ukraine dagegen hält dass
keiner jubelt das Millionen Menschen
wegrennen und dass dieser diese Ukraine
wehrhaft ist und in ihren Grenzen Ungarn
ungetastet bleiben will und insofern
sein wir werden dort nicht reingezogen
wir unterstützen und wie gesagt die
Alternative wäre wir machen nichts und
überlassen die Ukraine ihrem Schicksal
ich glaube das würde eine zurecht eine
Diskussion auslösen der eine ganz andere
Dimension hat und das natürlich Russland
Szenarien also militärische Szenarien
aufstellt um Angst zu machen das ist im
Krieg nichts Neues früher hat man ja
Flugblätter abgeworfen heute nutzt man
auch die sozialen Medien um Menschen zu
verunsichern und der einzige Sinn diese
Aktion von Russland ist natürlich die EU
zu spalten die einer Meinung war und
hoffentlich noch ist die NATO zu spalten
es gab noch nie ein so enges Vorgehen 30
NATO-Staaten macron Präsident macron hat
noch vor zwei Jahren vom Hirntod der
NATO gesprochen und Finnland und
Schweden neutrale Länder diskutieren
jetzt gerade und werden bald in ihren
Parlamenten abstimmen ob sie nicht Teil
der NATO werden Gänze genommen will ich
damit sagen dass Putin eben die Rechnung
nicht aufging und er deswegen große
Szenarien an und sendet davon sollten
wir die sollten wir sehr ernst nehmen
weil wir sollten das auch ähm ja das mit
sehr großer Sachlichkeit begleiten wir
sind ein bisschen überrascht man sieht
das auch so ein bisschen in den
Kommentaren dass sie vergleichsweise
sagen wir mal zurückhaltend sind gerade
in diesem Gespräch in ihrer Kritik am
Bundeskanzler und an der
Regierungslinie wir erinnern uns sie
haben nach der Rede von Olaf Scholz am
Dienstag von einem dröhnenden Schweigen
der Regierung gesprochen und die seine
Worte als verbales Hütchenspiel
bezeichnet was ist passiert Frau Streik
Zimmermann warum sind sie heute so wenig
auf Krawall gebürstet
also ich hoffe vor ungarn-sternberg dass
sie mich nicht eingeladen haben damit
ich hier kavalig bin sondern dass wir in
einen sachlichen Austausch treten so wie
wir das hier auch in meinem Büro und im
Umfeld meiner Fraktion und mit den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Austausch
machen ich habe ich habe mehrmals gesagt
dass ich die Kommunikation
unterirdisch finde ich habe mehrmals
erklärt dass ich das bedauerlich finde
dass der Bundeskanzler sich führt nicht
die Fäden zusammenführt daran ändert
sich überhaupt nichts aber wenn sie mich
einladen sachlich zu antworten auf die
interessanten Fragen ihrer Zuhörerinnen
und Zuhörer dann hat es keinen Sinn hier
rumzufoltern meine Meinung kennen sie
das ist ein Akt unter vielen und da
bitte ich auch um Verständnis dass wir
auch seriös Antworten müssen damit sie
wissen es geht hier nicht ums
draufschlagen der Kanzler da können Sie
sicher sein wenn der mich sieht oder
meinen Namen hört stehen dem
wahrscheinlich die ich hätte jetzt fast
gesagt die Haare zu Berge dass wir zu
blödes Bild
aber wird er wird er Nord im just sein
wenn er mit mir konfrontiert wird da
können Sie sicher sein aber wir müssen
schon sachliche Antworten geben damit
auch die die Fragen stellen verstehen
und was es geht aber dann da um Himmels
willen es geht uns nicht um Krawall den
wollen wir ja gar nicht produzieren aber
wir leben erleben natürlich dass es
diesen Krawall tatsächlich auch schon
gibt innerhalb der Bundesregierung
schauen wir uns mal an was Rolf Mütze
nicht gesagt hat der
SPD-Fraktionschef der sich nämlich
genötigt sah in Anbetracht der aktuellen
Lage ein Schreiben an seine Fraktion zu
schicken hören wir mal rein
Preis bewusst falsch darstellen zeigt
dass es diesen offensichtlich um mehr
als um eine kritische Begleitung der
deutschen Sicherheitspolitik geht vieles
davon macht den Eindruck dass die Kritik
nur am Rande von der Sorge um die
Ukraine motiviert ist
Frau Schreck Zimmermann wir sind Sie
kein Mitglied der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
das richtet sich an die eigene Fraktion
aber wir müssen feststellen auch aus
ihren Reihen und sie sind ja auch
Koalitionspartner und auch aus ihrem
Mund ganz persönlich hat es sehr sehr
scharfe Kritik gegeben das ist ja eine
Tatsache
ja es hat scharfe Kritik gegeben und
Rolf Mütze nicht hat ja die Reise meiner
Kollegen Michael Roth und Anton
Hofreiter kritisiert als
Selbstdarstellung das ist schon
bemerkenswert für ein Parlamentarier das
wenn wir Gäste wenn wir eingeladen
werden in das Land zu kommen was gerade
überfallen wurde dass wir dorthin reisen
und er das so begleitet ich habe auf
Twitter entsprechend reagiert dieser
Brief von dem sie jetzt gerade Auszüge
vorgelesen haben ist ein interner Brief
von der Mütze nicht an seine eigenen
Leute ich pflege nicht diese Briefe
anderer Fraktion zu kommentieren da sie
mich aber jetzt damit konfrontieren
unterstellt er ja uns dreien den zweiten
Kollegen und mir wir hätten persönliche
Hintergründe das zu machen wenn ich ihn
jetzt alleine hier sitzen hätte würde
ich zu ihm sagen es ist einfach nur
Unverschämtheit was er daraus Haut aber
ich lasse mich von Rolf Mütze nicht
jetzt auch nicht weiter der beunruhigen
wenn er meint dass er seine eigenen
Fraktion einen solchen Brief schreiben
muss dann ist das ihm unbenommen wir
haben auch eine eigene Fraktion und
tauschen uns aus und die Meinung von
Mütze nicht ist ja bekannt er lebt in
einer anderen Zeit er hat noch nicht
mitbekommen offensichtlich was gerade
passiert und das nehmen wir zur Kenntnis
das ist jetzt aber nicht neu sondern das
kennen wir von ihm nicht anders
das kommentiere ich jetzt mal nicht
sondern sage an dieser Stelle vielen
Dank
mir ich hätte jetzt Lust das Gespräch an
dieser Stelle zu vertiefen aber wir
wollen ja jetzt auch nicht weiter über
die Regierungskoalition streiten sondern
das Thema ist Waffenexporte in die
Ukraine vielen Dank Frau Zimmermann
erlauben sie ja er ich mir noch einen
Satz weil mir das wirklich wichtig ist
wenn wir eine andere Regierung hätten
eine große Koalition glauben Sie mir
auch dort würden Diskussionen geführt
Deutschland ist auf diese Situation dass
ein Krieg ausbricht in Europa und uns
unmittelbar tangiert als Europäerin
Europäer das hat Deutschland bis dato
nicht lernen müssen das ist eine gute
Nachricht aber die schlechte Nachricht
ist dass wir auch lernen müssen mit
Krisen umzugehen und das muss jeder der
an seiner Stelle ist der Bundeskanzler
die
ministerausschussvorsitzende
Parlamentarier und Parlamentarier müssen
das Lernen und deswegen dass wir jetzt
Rauch in der Luft ist finde ich
persönlich nicht schlimm das gehört dazu
und diese Koalition macht Freude und
dass wir in keinem Koalitionsvertrag
steht was machen wir eigentlich wenn ein
Krieg ausbricht
insofern finde ich das als Demokraten
einen richtigen Vorgang und ich Raufe
mich gerne aber mir war wichtig auch
seriös Antworten zu geben damit klar ist
dass wir das hier sehr sehr ernst nehmen
mit dem täglich konfrontiert sind vielen
Dank dann nehmen wir zur Kenntnis das
aus ihrer Sicht das Regieren in dieser
Konstellation Freude macht und neben
aber tatsächlich auch noch mal mit denn
das ist der Titel dieser Sendung die
Frage wie das international wahrgenommen
wird aus der regierungsposition haben
wir das jetzt denke ich gut behandelt
vielen Dank Frau Strack Zimmermann dass
Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren und
damit gehen wir tatsächlich weiter mit
der Frage wie wird das international
wahrgenommen und da schauen wir noch mal
ins Netz und sehen Timothy Schneider
einen der wichtigsten Autoren und
intellektuellen Wissenschaftler aus
Amerika der heute auch getwittert hat
unter den Ländern die der Ukraine
geholfen hat haben hat Estland am
meisten und Deutschland am wenigsten
geholfen im Verhältnis zum
Bruttoinlandsprodukt also Timothy
Sneider ist es offenbar wichtig darauf
hinzuweisen welche Rolle international
Deutschland spielt und das bringt uns
dazu bei unserem USA Korrespondenten
nachzufragen
ist für uns in Washington Elmar wie
beobachten die Amerikaner wie viel
Freude macht es den Amerikanern den
deutschen gerade beim Regieren
zuzugucken um das Wort von Frau
Zimmermann aufzunehmen
ja hier wird in Amerika natürlich auch
nur tiert ich sag mal mit Worten wie
zaudernd oder zögerlich oder er läuft
der Dynamik hinterher das was Olaf
Scholz und die Ampelkoalition in Berlin
für Probleme haben man hat auch ein
Stück weit Verständnis aus der deutschen
Geschichte heraus aber ich erinnere mich
vor einigen Wochen als die zeitenwände
verkündet wurde da haben viele hier sehr
begeistert reagiert dass Deutschland
endlich diese Verantwortung auch
übernimmt über die man eigentlich schon
seit den 90er Jahren spricht eben nach
dem Ende des Kalten Krieges damals hat
George Bush senior ja davon gesprochen
Partner ist in leadership also Partner
bei der Führung in dieser Welt jetzt
endlich übernehme Deutschland die
Verantwortung und damals vor ein paar
Wochen hatte man auch ein paar kritische
Stimmen die wurden nicht öffentlich so
laut geäußert ob das auch wirklich so
kommt mit der Zeitenwende jetzt werden
diese stimmen hier lauter in den
amerikanischen Medien offiziell sagt die
Regierung nichts Kritisches über die
Bundesregierung aber den Kulissen hört
man eben auch dass seine Menge auf dem
Spiel steht wenn die Bundesregierung
nach den großen Worten von zeitenwände
nicht wirklich auch stärker sich
beteiligt immer dann schauen wir noch
mal gemeinsam auf den Tweet von Wolfgang
Ischinger den ich vorhin schon zitiert
habe der endet mit der Frage oder mit
der mit der Sorge welche Folgen das für
Deutschland und die EU hätte falls
Russland den Krieg in der Ukraine
gewinnen würde und man bei den Deutschen
als Schuldigen bleibt was hätte das für
Folgen
ja ich glaube das würde das deutsche
Image massiv beschädigen egal mit wem
wir hier reden ehemalige Botschafter
ehemalige Regierungsbeamte auch einige
von den Aktiven Regierungsbeamten die
glauben eben dass es am Ende eine
strategische Niederlage geben müsse für
Vladimir Putin wenn das nicht geschieht
dann hätte Europa ein Problem weil das
eine Ermutigung wäre möglicherweise
weiterzugehen Moldau baltische Staaten
und andere dann hätte man das Problem
unmittelbar mit der NATO wenn es um die
baltischen Staaten geht und deswegen
sagt man hier auch wenn Deutschland sich
nicht mit an die Spitze der Bewegung
setzt dann sendet das natürlich einen
ein fatales Signal auch an andere Länder
in Europa hier wird notiert wenn die
Niederlande Niederlande bereit sind eben
auch Waffen zu liefern wenn die USA
wissen und das wird hier auch diskutiert
dass in Deutschland beispielsweise aber
einem Privatunternehmen etwa 100 Leopard
1 Panzer herumstehen die einsetzbar
wären nach Angaben des Unternehmen
selber dann fragt man sich schon ob
nicht die Bundesregierung ein Stück weit
auch eine größere Rolle dabei spielen
könnte solche Waffensysteme
ausgemusterte Leopard 1 zum Beispiel zu
liefern dass die Ukrainer mit so einem
Material umgehen können davon ist man
hier in den USA überzeugt weil man hat
in den letzten Monaten sehr intensiv
eben auch die ukrainischen Soldaten auf
amerikanisches Gerät trainiert was ja
jetzt tatsächlich auch zum Einsatz kommt
immer ich guck hier immer kurz in den
Chat und sehe direkt hintereinander zwei
total gegensätzliche Kommentare die die
Diskussion genau abbilden Bob Schmidt
schreibt auf Youtube ich finde auch wir
sollten keine Waffen liefern und unten
drunter schreibt Edding Player 5 so
schnell wie möglich Waffen für die
Ukraine also auch hier sind die
Meinungen sehr geteilt und Andreas
Schulz schreibt in den US-Medien kommt
Deutschland gar nicht vor was sagst du
dazu
ja das stimmt nicht wir sehen sowohl in
den Artikeln über das was in Deutschland
passiert New York Times Washingtons auch
bei den großen Nachrichten Networks CNN
NBC aber eben auch bei Forks das
Deutschland immer wieder vorkommt in den
Diskussionen der Experten die dort
auftreten aber es ist in der Tat so dass
die US-Regierung das Thema selber nicht
aus Tapete bringen man äußert keinerlei
Kritik an Deutschland sondern bekräftigt
eigentlich immer nur wie wichtig es ist
sich einig zu sein das hat Joe Biden
heute morgen auch wieder gemacht als er
ja bekannt gegeben hat dass die
Amerikaner 72
Artilleriegeschütze vom Typ Howitzer an
die Ukraine liefern werden die
entsprechende Munition auch in großer
Zahl 121 Drohnen und er redet dann eben
immer von der Wichtigkeit dieser
Geschlossenheit der Verbündeten in
dieser Sache und hat heute morgen ein
neues Schlagwort im Grunde genommen
genutzt der hat gesagt das ist die
Frontlinie der Freiheit die verteidigt
werden muss und da seht schon das wissen
wir aus Hintergrundgesprächen das Weiße
Haus die Administration hier Deutschland
in der Pflicht aber noch mal offen gibt
es bisher keine Kritik an der
Bundesregierung
sind vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzungen aus Washington ein
Dankeschön möchte ich dir noch zum
Abschied mit auf den Weg geben Jens o
schreibt über Youtube bisher eine sehr
gute Sendung ich fühle mich informierte
als bei anderen Sendern das gebe ich
auch gerne nach Washington weiter vielen
Dank für die Einschätzungen aus den USA
und ich möchte gerne das was Frau Strack
Zimmermann zum Thema Kommunikation des
Bundeskanzlers aufgreifen und vertiefen
und vielleicht bevor wir zu Christian
Mölling von der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für auswärtige Politik gehen schauen wir
noch mal kurz an was Lars Klingbeil
heute morgen gesagt hat hier im ZDF
Morgenmagazin der
SPD-Parteivorsitzende der die Art
Politik zu machen von Olaf Scholz dort
noch mal begründet verteidigt hat
wir haben es gleich es war wie gesagt
schon heute morgen deshalb müssen wir
ein bisschen suchen bis wir uns finden
aber jetzt ist es da
es ist richtig dass wir in dieser
jetzigen Situation ein Bundeskanzler
haben der mit Bedacht führt der überlegt
führt der Sachen auch vom Ende her denkt
der sich abstimmt mit internationalen
Partnern und es gibt keine einfachen
Antworten auf komplexe Situationen
deutschland hat in den letzten Wochen in
der Qualität und der Quantität von
Waffen die wir liefern deutlich erhöht
und wir sind darüber mit den Partnern
auch in der täglichen Abstimmung wir
sehen wie Russland gerade die Art der
Kriegsführung verändert dann müssen wir
auch die Frage der Waffenlieferung
anpassen also das was wir mit
Panzerfäusten tun mit der Flugabwehr tun
mit der Artillerie tun das international
jetzt zum Beispiel auch russische
sowjetische ehemalige Panzer geliefert
werden das sind ja alles Dinge die wir
international abstimmen aber es gibt
keine Vorlage die man irgendwo aus der
Schublade zieht wo man sagt so und so
funktioniert das
tja so weit also der
SPD-Parteivorsitzende und da ist er Dr
Christian Mölling Sicherheitsexperte von
der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik fragt Zimmermann ist
sehr auf die Kommunikation des
Bundeskanzlers eingestiegen würden Sie
sagen da ist noch sehr viel Luft nach
oben oder würden Sie Herrn klingenball
Recht geben und sagen besser mit ruhiger
Hand sowie Olaf scholzes macht
ich glaube ich würde Frau stark
Zimmermann Recht geben da ist sicher der
Luft nach oben ich will es mal so
versuchen zu formulieren
wir haben auf der einen Seite eine
Bundesregierung die sehr viel mehr tut
aber sehr wenig erklärt wir haben aber
in der Vergangenheit gelernt ein ganz
schrecklichen Beispielen wie der
US-Administration zusammen mit Donald
Trump die dass die Kommunikation und das
was man tut das Handeln und das sagen
wenn das sich zusammenpasst sind alle
verwirrt und ich glaube das ist ein
Zustand nicht der Verwirrung aber das
des Wunders der beschreibt was in den
letzten Tagen sowohl hier in Deutschland
stattgefunden hat als auch bei unseren
internationalen Partnern wie gesagt
verständlichen Abrieb dass Deutschland
mehr leistet aber es stellt doch in
Aussicht dass es uns helfen würde uns
allen helfen würde wenn die
Bundesregierung sich einfach schneller
erklären würde und damit das Gute was
sie tut auch besser erklären könnte
dann kommen wir zum inhaltlichen dazu
gibt es viele Fragen Dirk Lange fragt
zum Beispiel über Youtube wieso kann
eigentlich nicht direkt bei der
Industrie Waffen gekauft werden wieso
dieser Ringtausch wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe ist beides vorgesehen
können Sie das noch mal ein bisschen
aufdröseln ja also die Industrie hat
nichts was sie sozusagen von der Stange
Weg jetzt liefern kann es ist kein
Kaufhaus wo man reingeht und
insbesondere schwere Waffen dann einfach
mal heute bestellt und morgen abholt es
gibt kein Amazon sozusagen dafür sondern
was man hier macht ist man geht bewusst
auch eine Lücke ein das heißt einige
Staaten Mittelosteuropas liefern und
Deutschland hat zugesagt dass jetzt dann
die Industrie die Dinge die da stehen
die aber erst wieder
aufmunitioniert werden müssen und
sozusagen fit gemacht werden müssen dass
die später dann in diese Länder
geliefert werden das heißt also hier
geht es einen gewissen Zeitverzug das
ist das was drin ist aber und das ist
glaube ich in der Prioritätensetzung
sehr richtig
man liefert jetzt was man kann und ich
glaube sowohl die Bundesregierung als
auch die Ukraine sind diesen anderen
Ländern dankbar dass die ihre
Materialien jetzt zur Verfügung stellen
sehr schnell und in den nächsten Tagen
kommen denn das Material wird jetzt
gebraucht wir haben jetzt die neue
Offensive die läuft das heißt der geht
ganz viel Material einfach kaputt in so
einem Kampf und das muss sehr schnell
ersetzt werden wenn ich vielleicht noch
einen Punkt aufnehmen darf den Last
klingbar eben gemacht hat wenn der
Kanzler und auch alle anderen vom Ende
her denken dann finde ich das ja sehr
super ich würde mir dann wünschen dass
wir nicht nur über die nächsten zwei
Wochen der Offensive reden sondern dass
wir darüber reden was kommt denn dann
danach also das heißt irgendwann ist das
Material das jetzt geliefert wird auch
verbraucht darüber sollte man nicht erst
in zwei oder drei Wochen reden sondern
darüber müssten wir im Grunde heute
reden wenn wir strategisch an die Sache
herangehen wollen und vom Ende entdecken
wollen und dann bedeutet das weil eben
kein sowjetisches Material mehr da ist
das dann WE das Material genutzt werden
muss oder aber wir wollen die Hilfe für
die Ukraine einstellen weil wir sagen
wir können nichts mehr bereitstellen das
heißt aus meiner Sicht brauchen wir
jetzt eine Diskussion darüber was wir
bereit sind an weiteren Lücken in der
Landesverteidigung bündnisverteidigung
einzugehen um es der Ukraine zur
Verfügung zu stellen die Diskussion wird
zurzeit vor uns ich würde sagen
vielleicht hergeschoben aber wir führen
sie zumindest auf alle Fälle nicht weil
sie natürlich bedeutet dass wir wieder
in sehr unangenehme Fragen reinkommen
und vor allen Dingen diejenigen sich
dann zu Wort melden die seit Wochen
sagen es lohnt eigentlich sowieso nicht
die Ukraine zu unterstützen
dann greifen wir genau eine dieser
Positionen mal auf
bevor wir zum O-Ton kommen noch einen
user-kommentar Ichi Horn schreibt über
Youtube was würde passieren wenn die
Ukraine sich morgen ergeben würde und
dazu ergänzend der gerade schon
angekündigte O-Ton nehme ich von Ralf
Stegner der auch immer wieder dieses
Szenario ins Spiel bringen zuletzt bei
Markus Lanz hören wir mal kurz rein
ohne nato-beteiligung ist der Krieg
vermutlich militärisch nicht zugunsten
der Ukraine zu entscheiden und die
Lösung wird am Ende wieder eine
politische sein müssen das sagen auch
Generäle in
ist das eine Einschätzung die sie teilen
ist das was man ohne direkte
nato-beteiligung im Moment tut nämlich
Waffen liefern zu wenig ist damit am
Ende die Ukraine zur Niederlage
verurteilt und nur wenn es tatsächlich
ein aktives Engagement der NATO gäbe
wäre dieser Krieg zu gewinnen das will
aber wiederum keiner weil niemand den
NATO Bündnis fallen möchte
also ich teile diese Einschätzung nicht
ich würde sie eigentlich auch ganz gerne
damit Evidenzen
hinterlegen warum ich das nicht Teile
wir haben uns alle in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten massiv verschätzt
die Bundesregierung hat sich verschätzt
bis zum 24.2 wo sie gedacht hat dass
dieser Krieg nicht eintreten wird und
viele viele Leute in im Parlament haben
sich auch verschätzt es konnte sich
keiner vorstellen dass der Krieg kommt
und wir konnten uns auch danach nicht
vorstellen viele von uns nicht dass die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine so tapfer
kämpfen und mit großer Moral und mit dem
wenigen Material dass sie haben das auch
nicht besonders überlegen ist das
leisten was sie hingekriegt haben und
man sieht auch das westliche
Unterstützung einen Unterschied gemacht
hat und die Ukraine haben schnell
gelernt mit den Systemen umzugehen warum
man jetzt auf diesen Erfahrungen nicht
aufbauen will oder sie möglicherweise
dabei Seite wischt ist mir ehrlich
gesagt etwas unerklärlich und
stattdessen sagen die Ukraine müsste
aufgeben sie hat keine Chance ich glaube
sie hat eine Chance sie hat nur dann
keine Chance wenn Deutschland von
vornherein aufgibt und den Kopf in den
Sand steckt das ist glaube ich aber zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt Gott sei Dank mit
Blick auf die Bundesregierung nicht die
die Position die man hier einnimmt
sondern man sagt wir wollen helfen und
wir gucken dass wir alles mögliche nach
vorne bringen noch einen Punkt dazu zu
dieser sehr wie ich finde simplen und
auch falschen Logik wenn der Krieg
vorbei ist ist das ist das Leid der
Menschen vorbei und ist das Sterben der
Menschen vorbei nein wir halben Jahr
zahlreiche Berichte darüber dass auch in
den Gebieten wo nicht mehr gekämpft wird
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer deportiert
werden sie werden nach Russland gebracht
in andere Teile Russlands gebracht das
heißt also das Leiten ist nicht zu Ende
es heißt im Grunde genommen nur wir
übergeben die Ukraine und Ukraine die
noch auf dem Territorium sind den Russen
und was die vorhaben haben sie relativ
klar gemacht sie haben gesagt dass all
diejenigen die sie sozusagen sich zum
ukra Internationalismus bekennen das ist
ein Euphemismus dass die im Grunde
genommen kein Recht haben weiterhin zu
leben das heißt also zu glauben wenn der
Krieg vorbei wäre oder zumindest immer
die Panzerschlachten vorbei während wäre
das Leiden zu Ende auch dafür gibt es
gar keine Nachweise
Erich schreibt auf Youtube man kann
nicht gegen Krieg sein und gleichzeitig
Waffen liefern
ja doch das kann man also ich bin auch
gegen Krieg
aber die Frage ist ist man komplett
blind das ist trotzdem Krieg geben kann
also sie mögen ja gegen Krieg sein aber
der Krieg hat trotzdem ein Interesse
daran dass sie dass sie sich daran
beteiligen und sie haben eine Pflicht
sich zu beteiligen jetzt müsste
moralische pflichtig zu beteiligen das
sieht auch die un-karte vor die un-kater
sieht vor auch wenn es dort ein
Friedensgebot gibt und ein Verbot des
Angriffskrieges gibt es trotzdem da den
Eventualfall das so etwas stattfinden
kann so wie es jetzt stattfindet
Russland führt ein Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine und es gibt dann das Recht
sich zu verteidigen das kann man aber
nur wenn man Waffen hat
Waffenlieferungen sind dann in Ordnung
ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter gehen es wäre besser gewesen die
Ukraine in den letzten Jahren seit 2014
massiv und systematisch aufzurüsten so
dass sie sich besser verteidigen können
wenn ein wäre es möglicherweise so
gewesen dass die Ukraine gar nicht
angegriffen gewesen wäre denn dann hätte
man die Rechnung von von Verlusten für
Russland von Deutsch von vornherein
deutlich anders aussehen lassen außer
hätte damit rechnen müssen dass es viel
stärkere Verluste einfährt und
möglicherweise sich von der Krieg den es
jetzt führt im Grunde genommen
verabschiedet und auch hier muss man
ganz klar sagen dass die Bundesregierung
erst jetzt in diesem Jahr und viele
andere feststellen
das Russland ein aggressiver Neo
imperialer Start ist der im Grunde
genommen alte Ideen von von von von von
einem russischen Imperium
wiederherstellen will das sind Dinge die
wir spätestens seit 2014 eigentlich
wissen und die andere auch wissen
konnten die Frage ist wollte man sich
dieses Wissen zu eigen machen oder hat
man lieber auf den Prämissen aufgebaut
von dem man glaubte dass sie eigentlich
ewigen Frieden versprechen
eine Frage zum Abschluss die an das
anknüpft was Toni Hofreiter befürchtet
nämlich die Sorge vor einem Dritten
Weltkrieg wenn man die Ukraine nicht
ausreichend unterstützt in diesem Kampf
gegen die russische Invasion wie sehr
folgen Sie dieser Argumentation
ich glaube dass man
eine sehr feine Linie hier im Grunde am
ziehen muss oder im Klaren Korridor es
ist so
dass die Ukraine auf der einen Seite in
die Lage versetzt werden muss
souverän über ihr eigenes Schicksal zu
entscheiden das kann sie zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht weil russisches Militär
auf dem Staatsgebiet steht was wir aber
auf der anderen Seite auch nicht haben
wollen ist dass die Ukraine so
übermächtig wird und auf einmal
Russland überrennt so dass Moskau dann
in der Tat die Möglichkeit nur noch
sieht zu den äußersten Mitteln zugreifen
also möglicherweise
Nuklearwaffen auf dem Gefechtsfeld
einzusetzen das ist nichts was die was
wir wollen wir wollen auch keine
Implosion Russlands haben und hier geht
es darum mit einer sehr klaren wiederum
vom Ende hergedachten Strategie und da
würde ich der Bundesregierung
unterstellen dass sie diese Dinge mit
dem Blick hat zu überlegen was sind die
richtigen Maßnahmen so dass wir
der der Ukraine ihre Souveränität
zurückgeben können aber gleichzeitig
Russland nicht in einen wie soll man
sagen in ein versagenden Staat führen
indem es daher zu einem Kollaps kommt
das ist auch kein Interesse dass wir
haben von daher teile ich die Sorge auf
der einen Seite ja aber ich glaube man
kann sie qualifizieren man kann sagen
diese Sorge ist weniger berechtigt wenn
man dafür sorgt dass auch die Ukraine
hier klar im Auge im Auge haben dass sie
mitverantwortlich sind wenn alles gut
geht für die europäische Sicherheit und
auch eine konstruktive Rolle spielen
können das sind sie jetzt schon die
übernehmen jetzt schon eine wichtige
Aufgabe für die europäische Sicherheit
das heißt aber auch in der Offensive hat
man irgendwann eine Aufgabe für die
europäische Sicherheit weil am Ende des
Tages werden wir mit dem Ergebnis dieses
Krieges umgehen müssen
das ist allerdings tatsächlich schon
sehr sehr weit vorausgedacht weil man ja
auch überhaupt nicht absehen kann wie
sich Russland verhält nach oder während
dieser weiteren
weiterverlaufenden Auseinandersetzung in
der Ukraine oder Auseinandersetzung ist
es ja nicht es war ein Angriff
nein das kann man nicht
aber man kann ja trotzdem darüber
Überlegungen anstellen und es ist jetzt
auch nicht so dass Russland komplett
unberechenbar ist also soweit würde ich
auch nicht gehen das würde ja das würde
ja dramatisch sein ich glaube schon dass
man dass man Szenarien aufzeigen kann
wie Russland sich verhalten wird
und auch da hat Russland immer wieder
klar gemacht wenn es zu einer Bedrohung
der nationalen Sicherheit kommt dann ist
man bereit zum Äußersten zu gehen
deswegen darf das nicht passieren aber
es gibt graduelle Abstufungen ich glaube
das Besondere äh aber entschuldigung da
muss ich jetzt da muss ich hinaus noch
mal einhaken denn diese Bedrohung die
sehen ja die Russen offenbar so wenig
nachvollziehbar das ist schon eine ganze
Weile also mit diesem Bedrohungsszenario
was ja auch ein je nachdem wie man es
sieht aber das kann man ja auch als
totales Fake bezeichnen man kann ja
sagen diese Bedrohung die gibt es de
facto einfach nicht das ist eine
russische Erfindung also von daher ist
es schon schwer mit mit mit einem
berechenbaren Russland zu operieren
naja also ich glaube hier kommt es
wiederum darauf an dass sie im Grunde
genommen Taten und Worte in Einklang
bringen müssen das Russland böse Briefe
schreibt
weil Tschechien Waffen liefert naja klar
ja russland hat auch schon
Vertragsangebote gemacht im Dezember die
waren auch Fake das ist klar die Frage
ist hinterlegt Russland das mit mit
politisch anderen Signalen und das ist
etwas worauf man achten muss es geht
nicht nur um die Wörter und es gibt
nicht nur um das was getan wird sondern
die Frage ist worauf weist das im Grunde
genommen hin und auch sozusagen die
Frage des Verlaufes des Krieges auch das
gehört ja mit in diese Berechnung mit
rein und von daher würde ich an dem
Punkt eher noch mal darauf hinweisen das
ist für für viele von uns Neuland und
das macht große Unsicherheit weil wir
eigentlich viele gedacht haben wir leben
ab sofort im ewigen Frieden nach dem
Ende des Kalten Krieges und jetzt müssen
wir uns damit konfrontiert sehen mit
einer Situation die viele nicht haben
kommen sehen und andere auch gar nicht
haben wollen und wir müssen uns trotzdem
diesen schwierigen Fragen stellen das
heißt aber nicht dass wir deswegen den
Kopf in den Sand stecken müssen sondern
wir müssen ganz klar die
unterschiedlichen Optionen auf den Tisch
legen und sie politisch besprechen und
abwägen was sind die richtigen Maßnahmen
in diesem Zusammenhang und ich verstehe
das total dass es vielen Leuten dass es
vielen Leuten sorge bereitet aber das
andere ist eine Illusion das ist ein Weg
zurückgebe und dass man diesen Krieg
quasi abschalten würde und man dann da
wäre wo man vor einem 24.2 gewesen wäre
sagt Dr Christian Mölling vielen Dank
für ihre Einschätzungen auf diesem Wege
noch ein Kommentar von Liesel pompe über
Youtube die schreibt ich finde die
Aussagen dieses Mannes sehr klar und
verständlich also der Dank an dieser
Stelle und ich habe noch eine Frage zu
ihrer Bücherwand die sieht nämlich fast
genauso aus wie die von Frau Strack
Zimmermann die wir eben gerade gesehen
haben aber ich nehme an sie sitzen nicht
im selben Wohnzimmer ne eine Frau
schreibt Zimmermann hat eine viel
aufgeräumtere Bücherwand als ich meine
ist ständig in Bewegung wir müssen in
Bewegung sein haben wir links ich glaube
auch ich räume sie ständig um sie werden
das nächste mal eine andere Bücherei
oder ein anderes gestaffelte Bücher
anziehen ich verspreche ich solange sie
es nicht nach Farben sortieren ist alles
gut wir sind gespannt und freuen uns auf
das auf das nächste Mal
auf das nächste Mal Dankeschön für ihre
Expertise und Ihnen und Euch zu Hause
vielen Dank fürs Regen mit kommentieren
und Fragen stellen und bis zum nächsten
Mal sicherlich auch zu diesem Thema
tschüss